let's see who else is on the phone today
why don't we go to the to10 area code
two-one-zero which I believe is the San
Antonio area go ahead
hello yeah that's you yeah I want to ask
you something
who's this and where you're calling from
my name is Cesar I'm from San Antonio Ok
Go Ahead Cesar yeah I've noticed that
the Democratic Party isn't the party of
what it used to be I mean it used to be
the party of the working class in
helping the average American sure after
now that what I've seen I've seen how
they are acting they no longer care
about like real issues they're more
worried about stuff like identity
politics making making sure that nothing
is offensive to anyone ever again is
just whining and throwing temper
tantrums
this isn't be the party that I recognize
anymore I mean why has the party and
people on the list have regrets to this
type of behavior because I'm worried
that they're not going to win any
elections that they continue to act this
way Democrats not winning elections is a
real concern but let me ask you this
Cesar if I can which which prominent
elected Democrats do you feel are
focusing on identity politics not even
exact names but just jet-like can you
name can you name one for example like
can you name one elected Democrat whose
focus has become offending people or not
offending people and identity politics
well I've seen that um I see no
congressman Harris who's that
congressman Harris who's that do you
mean senator Canella Harris
yeah okay what did she do
well yeah what camel-hair is to look I'm
not talking about the specific people
I'm just talking I'm not talking about
politicians oh you're not people who now
talk about people like you know people
who call themselves Democrats people on
the left okay so this is not so you at
first you said that this was a concern
you had with the Democratic Party and
it's in the people who are running for
stuff making identity politics their
focus but now you're saying it's not a
problem among the elected people it's
just the voters yeah because I've seen
how they are acting in and I'm starting
and I'm starting to get worried that
that the party is changing too much but
so you're saying this isn't this is just
the voters but it's not the people who
are in power that are changing its own
the voters are changing but the people
in power are fine they're not doing the
identity politics stuff no oh so it
sounds like the actual people in power
haven't changed then right because
you're saying they're not doing the
identity politics stuff no I'm not
talking about what I mean the Democratic
Party when I mean I mean the people I
mean how they're behaving I mean our
supporters who are trying to urge other
people to vote you know was you know the
things that they want that they're not
acting very civilized but you're saying
that you're saying that people on the
Left who are trying to get people to
vote are doing something wrong yeah
that's what I'm saying I'm not talking
about the politicians but what are the
people doing wrong by trying to get
others to vote isn't that a good thing
no no I'm saying I'm seeing like when
you do things like silence like speak
other from the other side and just just
rioting and breaking stuff that where
have their nonviolent riots with
property destruction what happened where
where have these violent riots with
property breaking stuff where has
property been destroyed by violent
leftist rioters well talked about well
when I swing at you saw on the news want
to break you stuff okay but an tifa's
like almost nobody like it barely exists
it's not it has nothing to do with you
started with the Democratic Party now
you're talking about a antifa is ante if
I even registered to vote do they even
vote no I just hope I think what pshh
do is that people should just stay away
from the from the bad part of the left
you know yeah okay I agree with you
there I agree with you there all right
thank you for the call I man that that
was uh we were waiting for a call like
that today and we got it I don't think
that they they necessarily knew what
what point they were trying to make
there